Welcome to the Genius Factory. Enjoy the
video. In this video, I will show how to
program Toyota Corolla key fob updated.
Start with two working keys and sit in
the driver's seat with all doors closed.
I will walk you step by step through the
on vehicle programming routine, explain
common error lights, and offer
troubleshooting tips for when a fob
still refuses to sync, all in clear,
friendly language for hands-on doers.
Begin by inserting the master key and
cycling the ignition between off and run
positions as required by your Corolla
model to trigger programming mode. When
the system signals readiness, press the
lock button on the new fob firmly and
promptly. Then repeat for additional
remotes. Finish by turning the ignition
off and testing each function from
inside and outside the vehicle to ensure
full remote operation and door lock
response. If programming fails, first
swap in a fresh battery and retry the
sequence since weak batteries often
cause issues. Confirm the replacement
fob matches your Corolla's frequency and
compatibility because many aftermarket
units look similar but lack programming
support. If problems persist, use a
latch and key diagnostic. Check for
blown fuses. and consider contacting a
dealer or certified locksmith who can
read error codes and use specialized
equipment to complete the job. Thanks
for watching. If you found this helpful,
don't forget to like and subscribe.